FRONT LINES.
BUT FIRST, ROSANNE AND THE RACE
TO BLAME TRUMP.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW IT, WE SOLVED
A TWITTER MYSTERY.
WELL DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF MAY
HAVE WELL TAKEN POSSESSION OF
ROSEANNE BARR'S ACCOUNT AND IT
TAPPED OUT THE TWEET THAT LED TO
THE DEMISE OF HER HIT SITCOM AND
HER ENTIRE CAREER.
LISTEN CLOSELY.
ALL ROADS LEAD BACK TO TRUMP.
>> WE KNOW WHAT DONALD TRUMP
THINKS.
WE KNOW WHAT ROSEANNE BARR
IT'S TIME FOR US TO STOP PLAYING
AROUND WITH SOFT WORDS, BY
SAYING OH, WELL, THEY ARE SAYING
INSENSITIVE THINGS.
NO, IT'S RACIST.
THEY ARE EXHIBITING RACIST
BEHAVIOR.
>> I'M NOT SOMEONE WHO HAS
TRUMPS ARRANGEMENT SYNDROME AND
BLAMES DONALD TRUMP FOR
EVERYTHING BUT, THIS RIGHT HERE
IS A DIRECT BYPRODUCT OF HOW
DONALD TRUMP BEHAVES.
>> THE THING THAT A SORT OF THE
BACKGROUND OF ALL OF THIS IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT CAN BE
RACIST, AND NOTHING HAPPENED TO
HIM.
>> Laura: SO NOW THEY DO
BELIEVE IN GUILT BY ASSOCIATION.
WELL, THEY DIDN'T SUBSCRIBE TO
THIS BELIEF WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
>> NO NO NO.
GOD BLESS AMERICA.
AMERICA.
THAT'S IN THE BIBLE FOR KILLING
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> Laura: EVEN THOUGH
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAT IN JEREMIAH
WRIGHT'S P WAS YEARS MARINATING
IN THAT HATE, WE WERE TOLD THAT
HIS COMMENTS WERE NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF OBAMA'S OWN
BELIEFS.
THIS, DESPITE THE FACT THAT,
UNLIKE TRUMP AND ROSEANNE, THE
OBAMA'S WERE CLOSE TO RIGHT.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT'S SPIRITUAL
MENTOR FOR YEARS.
AND WHO CAN FORGET THIS 2005 JIM
WHICH WAS CONVENIENTLY HIDDEN
FROM PUBLIC VIEW BY THE
PHOTOGRAPHER FOR YEARS.
THAT'S A BUTTE.
WELL, WE NEVER SAW THAT PICK
UNTIL OBAMA LEFT OFFICE.
YOU SEE THE LEFT PROTECTS AND
DEFENDS THEIR OWN BECAUSE THEY
ARE IMMUNE TO CRITICIZE THEM FOR
THEIR UNSAVORY POLITICAL
ASSOCIATIONS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT CALLS AN
ACTRESS AND CONGRATULATES HER
FOR HER RATINGS SUCCESS, AND
SUDDENLY HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERYTHING SHE HAS EVER DONE OR
WILL DO.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT STARTED HIS CAREER ON THE
BREATH TERRORISM, SAYING HE
ISN'T ONE OF US, WHEN HE'S DONE
EVERYTHING HE CAN TO DO DOG
WHISTLING AROUND THIS ISSUE OF
RACE, PEOPLE LIKE ROSEANNE
FEEL THEY ARE EMPOWERED.
>> Laura: WHAT A FRAUD.
THIS IS THE MAN WHO BROUGHT US
THE FAKE TAWANA BRAWLEY CASE.
AND THAT WAS WHEN HE WASN'T
EVADING TAXES OR SHAKING DOWN
CORPORATIONS.
AND THIS IS WHO MSNBC WHEELS OUT
ON AS AN EXPERT.
SHARPTON ON BIGOTRY AND CIVILITY
IN AMERICA?
PLEASE.
THE LEFT HAS TO TAG IT
ROSEANNE'S RACIAL MISDEED TO
TRUMP, WHY?
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO SUBSTANTIVE
ANSWERS TO THE PROBLEMS FACING
MINORITY COMMUNITIES TODAY.
THEIR ONLY RECOURSE IS TO DO
THIS TO DEMONIZE THEIR
OPPONENTS.
MEANWHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ACTUALLY DELIVERING UNDENIABLE
RESULTS.
WE KNOW UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG
BLACKS AND HISPANICS IS DOWN TO
HISTORICAL LOWS.
WE KNOW THEY ARE TRYING TO READ
THEIR COMMUNITIES OF GANGS LIKE
MS-13, AND THE PRESIDENT IS
WORKING WITH CONGRESS TO PASS
PRISON REFORM.
ALL OF THIS HAS CAUSE TO
SUPPORT, AND GROW AMONG MINORITY
GROUPS, MODEST GAINS.
BUT THE LAST OF COURSE REFUSES
TO APPLAUD ANY OF TRUMPS
PROGRESS OR WORK WITH HIM, EVEN
ON ISSUES WHERE THEY HAVE COMMON
GROUND.
THAT IS HOW FANATICAL THEY ARE.
INSTEAD, WHAT THE LEFT DOES IS
THEY PLOT A WAY ON HOW TO
EXPLOIT THE NEXT MOMENT OF
RACIAL OUTRAGE.
HERE IS HOW HOOVER INSTITUTIONS
FELLOW AND PHENOMENAL AUTHOR
SHELBY STEELE WHO ACTUALLY LIVED
THROUGH SEGREGATION IN THE
SOUTH, HOW HE SEES IT FROM TODAY
ON THE RADIO SHOW.
>> IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT THE
AMOUNT OF CREATIVITY AND
IMAGINATION THAT GOES INTO SOME
REINVENTING RACISM,
VIRTUALIZATION IS POWER, AND IF
THE MONEY.
THIS -- THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PURSUING A RACE-FREE WORLD, A
WORLD FREE OF RACISM.
BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PURSUING WEALTH.
THEY ARE RACIAL ENTREPRENEURS.
THEY MAKE CAREERS OUT OF THIS.
THE WHITE MIDDLE CLASS TODAY IS
SADLY SUPPORTED BY DIVERSITY
WORK AND PROGRAMS.
>> Laura: AGAIN, THAT'S FROM
AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAN WHO
LIVED THROUGH REAL RACISM,
SUFFERED THROUGH SEGREGATION.
HIS COMMENTS?
WELL, PEOPLE OF COURSE READ IT
ROSEANN'S TWEET AS TOTALLY
BIASED.
SHE HERSELF SAYS IT'S
INDEFENSIBLE.
BUT THERE OTHER FORMS OF BIAS
THAT MALIGNING GOOD AND
HARDWORKING AMERICANS EVERY DAY.
REMEMBER THE WOMEN WHO VOTED FOR
TRUMP?
>> IN LIGHT OF THIS LAST
ELECTION, I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
US AS WOMEN, AND HOW WE THINK.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH OURSELVES AS
WOMEN.
THIS IS NOT AN EXTERNAL
CONVERSATION, THAT'S ON US.
>> Laura: THEN THEY HAVE
COMMENTS LIKE, FROM HER TELL US
WHAT TO DO.
REALLY?
A BLACK RAPPER WHO SUPPORTS
TRUMP.
>> CELEBRITIES LOOKING FOR
ATTENTION AND FINDING WAYS
WHETHER IT'S POSITIVE OR
NEGATIVE TO GET IT.
>> WIFE IS TWEETING BACK AND
FORTH THAT PEOPLE BASICALLY
SAYING DON'T BE TOO HARD ON MY
HUSBAND TO COME UP DON'T MAKE IT
SEEM LIKE IT'S GOING THROUGH
SOME KIND OF MENTAL BREAKDOWN.
AND WE THINK THAT HE HAS LOST
HIS MIND.
>> TRADITIONAL CHRISTIANS.
>> ONE THING TO TALK TO JESUS,
AND IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN
JESUS TALKS TO GO.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
THAT'S CALLED MENTAL ILLNESS IF
I'M NOT CORRECT.
>> Laura: WE ARE BASICALLY
TALKING PRETTY MUCH ABOUT ANY
AND ALL TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
>> YOU COULD PUT HALF OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INTO WHAT I CALL THE
BASKET OF DEPLORABLE'S.
>> Laura: WELL THINK ABOUT IT
THIS OTHER WAY.
IF TRUMP CREATED A SAFE SPACE
FOR ROSEANN TO WRITE THIS
INFLAMMATORY TWEET, MAYBE WITH
THAT DEPLORABLE'S COMMENT,
HILLARY CLINTON INSPIRED THIS.
>> TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
VOTED FOR HIM, AFTER HE SHOWED
HIS CARDS, FOR YEARS.
AND --
>> ARE YOU SAYING THEY WERE
RACIST?
>> YES.
>> Laura: WHILE THEY ARE
DEPLORABLE AFTER ALL.
ROSEANN HAS NOW BEEN
EXCOMMUNICATED FROM THE PUBLIC
SQUARE FOR COMMENTS THAT ABC
RIGHTFULLY CHARACTERIZED AS
ABHORRENT, REPUGNANT AND
INCONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUES.
MY QUESTION IS, WHEN WILL THE
DAY OF RECKONING COME FOR THOSE
ON THE LEFT, WHOSE OWN ABHORRENT
AND REPUGNANT VIEWS ARE